you
[Music]
so it's my pleasure to welcome mark
Breyers to MSR to give a talk today
entitled Turing Bayes and cybersecurity
markers of program director of security
of the alan turing institute prior to
that he worked for sixteen years in the
defense industry primarily in the areas
of statistical data analysis his
research interests include scalable
Bayesian inference sequential in ferns
and anomaly detection in particular the
areas of cyber security so thank you for
putting the talk is anymore no no thank
you
thank you for inviting me and thank you
for coming here on a early Wednesday how
kind of Wednesday first I have lost
control what the hair is jet lag in one
of you so thank you for thank you for
hosting me today so and what I want to
do is to split this talk essentially
into three parts I think I changed the
top title as well just to keep us all on
our toes so what I want to do is to
discuss the Alan Turing Institute's and
introduce that to your organization and
hopefully motivate you inspire you
convince you that it's a worthwhile
opportunity to collaborate with us if
that's of interest to you guys and then
kind of in some sense this segue from
touring and the turing institutes and
Alan Turing the man into the use of
Bayesian statistics in the context of
security related applications and
chewings work at Bletchley parks there's
a couple of slides on that and and some
relatively recent publications of Alan
Turing's that have been Declassified and
pushed out though that not many people
are aware of which demonstrates orange
juice of Bayes which is quite cool in my
opinion
and then finally try to kind of there's
so many tenuous links in this talk but
finally link the we kind of Bayesian
story to my work in cyber security and
give you an overview of what I'm trying
to achieve with the work at the
Institute in the context of cyber
security my background is I'm a
statistician by kind of PhD specifically
sequential Monte Carlo that was the
subjects of my PhD thesis and so you'll
see lots of use of those kinds of
algorithms and I've been taught Bayesian
statistics from from an undergraduate
level and so
all I know is based so if there's a
question my solution is is a Bayesian
solution so I will make a slight apology
for being completely kind of
short-sighted in my approach to things
so the Alan Turing Institutes I've got a
few slides on the island showing
institutes so we are a charity in the UK
and we were set up by the UK government
or formally announced in March 2014 and
what was happening in the UK and perhaps
around the world but specifically in the
context of the UK landscape there's lots
of work being done in Dayton oh well I
guess we'd now call it data science
perhaps we'd even call it artificial
intelligence given the kind of evolution
of the tags that get attached to these
kinds of data related activities but
back in the day it was referred to as
big data and so there are lots of
different initiatives research
initiatives or application relationships
happening in academia and in industry
there's lots of fragmentation even
within the UK so the UK government was
particularly keen to ensure that UK
society and UK PLC can benefit from
these activities and so they set up a
National Institute for data science and
artificial intelligence related research
to provide national level leadership and
ensure that UK society and in
collaboration with our international
partners internationally we can benefit
from research activities taking place in
these areas so the Institute's you can
think of as sitting at the centre of two
networks on one hand we've got a network
of academic related institutions and
I'll talk about that in more detail
shortly only other side we have a number
of industry or government related
partners through which we try to kind of
get real-world problems and ensure that
our research has real-world
applicability and our job is essentially
to try to kind of make some sense out of
all the stuff that's grown in academia
industry connect things up and provide
strategic leadership at the national
level alongside that were also expected
to train and educate everybody from you
know my some of my relatives who know
nothing about data science all the way
through to
professors who want to know more about a
specific specialized area so oh right
but to kind of provide training and
education as well so we've got quite a
big remit and and we get a reasonable
amount of funding from central
government which is actually funneled
through one of our research councils
similar to the NSF I guess
and so were considered to be a strategic
government's investments and that means
that what kind of you know we're not
we're not considered to be predatory in
any sense because we are charged so
we've got some charitable goals around
social good and training education
people don't see us as a threat to
commercial threat or otherwise they see
us as a way in which they can utilize
our expertise and the expertise that we
bring in to to benefit their
organisations and in doing so we can
benefit we can align ourselves to our
charitable girls so we've got a network
of university partners and I'll describe
how that works in a moment but these are
the university partners that we have at
the moment so we started off with five
universities when we were initially
created so we were announced by George
Osborne who's our who was our Chancellor
over the Exchequer back in 2014 we kind
of started in 2016 really doing any kind
of activity so October 2016 so rot two
years old now we started with five
universities so we had a competition in
the UK to decide the five best
universities in data science and AI and
the top five one and there'll be no
surprises there in terms of the kinds of
names these are household names in some
respects and then in the past six months
we've increased our network with eight
more universities when I would say 13
universities if I can count and and what
we do is we essentially secand academics
from these universities to work with us
and provide us with the intellectual
capital that we need to be able to
undertake the research activities that
we wish to undertake and I'll kind of
touch upon that like I say in a moment
just to show you that we're not London
centric so the cool thing is that well I
think it's cool cool thing is that the
Alan Turing Institute's kind of
headquarters is based in the British
Library in London
so if you ever get across to London them
do please drop me an email and my email
address is on the final slide and come
and visit us because we have the British
Library has some cool artifacts so Magna
Carta is hosted there and we actually
have an iPad coffee machine which is
another cool thing maybe it's not as
there is not secure in Microsoft you may
have those kinds of things but in the UK
that's kind of unique so it's one of the
kind of attracts evening so a Magna
Carta and I buy coffee machine and if
they can't attract you over to the UK
then I don't know what will and so we're
based in London and we have two
university partners also based on UCL
and Queen Marie and then we have kind of
universities based around the country
and so we have offices in each one of
these locations I suspect we'll have
representation in Northern Ireland and
in Wales in relatively short time skills
as well or I hope that from a personal
perspective so that we have full
geographic coverage across the UK in
terms of so that's the kind of academic
side in terms of the partners that we
have so when we first started again we
had four partners initially and so these
were kind of launched these were the
types of organisations that we were
working with so large register
foundation they are a chai tea
themselves and they own Lloyd's Register
which is an insurance company and that's
a commercial entity but the profits from
the commercial entity as I understand it
feedback into the charity and the
charity's mission is to essentially make
the world a safer place in which to live
and I guess that benefits the insurance
arm of the organisation but so large
register are particularly interested in
and they call it data centric
engineering so engineering of critical
national infrastructure to ensure the
safety and security of those kinds of
infrastructure maximize that Intel we're
interested in kind of car designing
chipsets and new algorithms guests are
generate and optimize their sales I
leave the interaction primarily with
these organizations so GCHQ which is the
UK equivalent of NSA our Ministry of
Defense and the ministry defence
research arm which is
defense science technology loves deer
steel and then finally one of our
partners HSBC and I've been told many
stories about HSBC but allegedly HSBC
has 20% of the world's financial
transaction trade flow data going
through the books and so that's quite a
lot of data and they want to be lots of
good things with that data and so
there's a core partnership happening
with HSBC I will go through all of these
because I realize it's a little bit
boring and the the partnership with
Microsoft is kind of one way of presence
and so we are very grateful and to
Microsoft for providing us with the
million pounds worth of as your credits
a year to do cool stuff but that's kind
of where the relationship ends you give
us a million pounds worth of credits and
and that's more or less it so part of my
motivation for being here is to try to
kind of reach out beyond that and those
are your credits and and make some kind
of meaningful attempt at collaboration
some of you may know Andrew Blake who is
the director of Microsoft Research
Cambridge as I understand it a few years
ago he was our initial director at the
Institute and I'm Trish now I moved on
to bigger and better things I'm told and
so there is a link between MSR on MSL
Cambridge at least and the Institute in
London and but like I say I'm really
keen to kind of develop those this
relationship so as I go through this
presentation if anything takes your
fancy then please do contact me and I
can arrange to link you up with the
specific academics or a more general
level so in terms of how were structured
how many people we have were not at the
MSR I'm kind of Sighs sadly but we do
have a reasonable amount of people at
least by UK standards so we have 250 or
over 250 touring fellows so we kind of
we have to use the word sure ringed in
front of everything that's the kind of
brand that we attach ourselves to but so
what that mean that means that we secand
in academics from our 13
université so these would be professors
all the way through to junior academics
working with us for one to three days a
week on specific research projects or
doing some of our teaching with us or or
appearing on the House of Lords
committees or trying to shape public
policy and do lots of different actives
we actually get them to do quite a lot
of work for us in lots of different ways
and it's an amazing academic community
so from the 13 best UK universities
we've then selected the 250 or so best
academics in this area to work with us
so we have a really great crew of
academics working with us and some of
the names I won't list them because I
don't want to show you demonstrate my
favourites academics but some of the
names I hope you will have come across
we have 19 of our own research for us
which really translates into an postdocs
we have about 50 PhD students we have an
internship program which is running at
the moment which I'll come back to at
the end over the summer period we have
quite a lot of visiting researchers from
academia industry and governments and
the UK government's in response to
brexit has introduced a scheme called
them Rutherford fellows and what that is
trying to do is to demonstrate that the
UK is an open and country which I hope
we I hope we always will be and and they
fund senior well great academics or
great researchers not academics great
researchers from around the world to
come and spend up to a year in the UK
working at different research
organisations or in industry so the
touring Institute's has been given quite
a bit of money to attract lots of people
into the UK so we've got six or seven
people from the u.s. actually come
across so people from staff stations for
instance from CMU are working with us
and spend in six months or so with us so
if there's any interest in that I'm not
quite sure what Microsoft position on
that would be but if that's of interest
then we have you know we have the
ability to kind of fund people to come
across and spend significant amounts of
time or reasonable amounts of time
working with us we have our own we call
them research engineers kind of software
engineers that are of more academically
minded than your average software
engineer we have a reasonable-sized
admin team because to manage 200
50 academics you almost need 500 her 500
sighs admin team but we we didn't go to
that order of magnitude we settled at 50
and we have seven program directors so
I'm one of the program directors at the
Institute we will have eight eventually
and that aligns to our eight programs
and eight challenges so the program
directors essentially control or leave
the research at the Institute's aligned
to one of these eight thematic areas and
this is Atiya this is a slide that's
been created by the marketing
departments so they get you can tell
they get less and less technical as the
marketing department get more and more
involved all right I should I should
remember that this has been publicly
released as well just in case the
marketing department watch this
presentation it's a great fantastic
slide but it's not the most technical
slide I've ever given so we're doing
work in healthcare as I mentioned we're
doing work in engineering I live the
work that we do in security where do you
work on economics with using HSBC data
but again focusing on our charts
projects on social good and education we
have quite a big thrust or big interest
in ethics and making machines they're
missing decisions fair transparent and
ethical I kind of switch upon this in
terms of our interactions with Intel and
designing computers and chipsets and
algorithms kind of code designing those
two we're doing work in science and
humanities and we are trying to foster
government innovation I'm still not
figured out what that actually means but
we're trying to make government more
efficient in every sense of the world
Atwood
so in terms of as you guys I'm sure know
statistics data science artificial
intelligence call it what you like
computer science I suppose has general
applicability and we were set up as this
National Institutes to derive benefit
from all the work that we undertake and
so what we decided to do was focus on
these eight application areas
essentially and we believe
the partners that we have if we do make
positive impacts in one or more of these
areas then we'll be able to meet our
charitable objects if so we focused on
eight areas which doesn't feel like that
much focus because actually each one of
these areas is huge in itself but it's
it's a level of focus it's as much focus
as we can kind of give ourselves at
present and we have a little bit of
technical focus although that the kind
of scientific strategy is still emerging
and I'll kind of propose a scientific
strategy or a rather a focus where I
think the Institute's is kind of best
placed to contribute scientifically and
that builds on our insurance legacy in
my opinion or one of these many
contributions to the scientific
literature but I'll come on to that in a
moment in terms of some of the Applied
Research Projects so again I'll just
give you a kind of very high-level
overview of the types of things we're
doing if any of these are of interest
they're publications on our websites we
we open source all the software that
would generate them essentially
everything we believe in reproducibility
we believe in openness etc so we're
trying to push everything out there so
that people can benefit from the work
that we do so just to give you a little
bit of an insight into the work that we
do so some of them are self explanatory
so digital twin this is related to the
work that we're doing with the large
register foundation so apparently
there's but a 3d printed bridge being
placed in Amsterdam and the plinth
sensors all over this bridge and it's
quite a cool video that I don't have on
my laptop of this bridge actually being
printed but they don't really understand
as I understand it they don't really
understand the long-term structural
integrity or structural properties of
this bridge and how it's going to
degrade as a function of time and so on
but they're instruments in it with lots
of sensors and so this projects all
about trying to make sense of that data
and making sure that the bridge you know
can hold people or vehicles or whatever
it's trying to hold so it's quite an
important project from that perspective
but as we start to 3d print more bridges
which aspects will happen in time you
know we need to be able to understand
the
types of data that coming from this type
of system the national economy
dashboards so this is where we're
utilizing the HSBC data so this is so
the UK government I'm 12 has a good
understanding of how much trade flows
say between the UK in the u.s. because
we know how much stuff goes over our
borders but actually they don't know how
much trade flows between London and
Manchester because this is not an easy
way of measuring that and so the HSBC
data gives us a proxy and it's measuring
and trade flows between different
geographical areas in the UK and that
allows us to essentially to produce GD
local GDP figures almost and optimize
national level kind of economic
strategies associated with the different
kind of flows of trade for instance
between different major cities in the UK
that's given the kind of the finance
part of the government's an ability to
optimize their interventions and I'm
sure there's a kind of political
dimension to that by I would hope that
they make all the decisions based on the
data that's in front of them but I
suspect that's not always the case and I
I guess there's I will go through all of
these because I realize it's kind of a
bit dull enough sat in the audience
listen to these kinds of talks myself so
how you to much like say if there's
anything on that slide that's of
interest then please do contact me or
visit our websites touring AC UK and and
you can find out more details in terms
of the work that I lead and I ask the
academics of work with the academics to
undertake theirs I've got three
multi-year research projects happening
at present and so god I think what we
did here was actually get the acronym
and then figure out what the name of the
project was retrospectively anyway
essentially God is about predicting
conflict so it's a combination of graph
theory and I mean incorporating into
those graphical representations from
stochastic differential equations and
some other things as a function of time
and integrating also different data sets
to be able to predict
areas that susceptible to conflict and
that could be so we've been working with
the Colombian government's for instance
on looking at different flux cartels and
how they how they interact or how they
shoot each other and then suggest
intervention strategies based on the
kind of geographical topology and some
of the work that we've been doing and
saying rights okay if you insert a
roadblock in this location and that's
likely to kind of reduce the amount of
shootings or interactions between these
different groups all the way up to the
kind of international level so you know
these types of areas are likely to be
that's what it's conflicts in the future
and critically because I'm a Bayesian
obviously I slap lied at prior
distributions over everything and we
quantify the uncertainty with everything
that we do which is kind of cool so
that's projects that's an interaction
between Warwick so during us juice
Warwick University and University
College London ADA is a bit like DARPA
z3m project but d3m is on a completely
different financial kind of scale as
she'd expected when darpur invest they
and best big whereas when we invest we
invest proportionally to how much money
we've got in the bank so in this project
there's an interaction between Cambridge
Edinburgh and Oxford universities and
maturing institutes basically what we
trying to do is to semi automate and
parse this data wrangling process over
looking at its a lot of Gaussian process
stuff if you see in the pinger Amani
talk about the automated statistician
and model selection and Gaussian
processes essentially that's kind of
what we're doing in this space and then
finally in terms of on this slide
computing and interested environments
what word in there is utilizing Intel's
SGX technology so we've gotten we've
just released a SGX compliant Linux
kernel library so SGX lk l lk s DX
cotton which we're under is and sitting
on top of that SG x compliance linux
kind of library we've actually placed
spark and you may think that's a trivial
operation but the memory footprint in SG
is quite small and so the interactions
that one has to do to get the to get
spark sitting and even just the JVM
sitting inside of SGX essentially an
encrypted memory is quite significant
and so what that is now giving us an
ability to do is to run containers
secure containers essentially in
cloud-based infrastructure and scale
outs use in sparks scalability
properties and say sure we've got full
end-to-end encryption now we've got
encryption at rest and we have
encryption using SGX
when data and processing capability is
in memory that's quite cool so we're
partnered with that's Cambridge Imperial
College showing institutes and we have
interactions with docker and in fact we
have interactions with MSR Cambridge on
that particular project too so that's
what we're in there and I will I promise
I'll get to some kind of technical
content at some point soon and then I've
kicked off actually a lot of these
projects are now ended but I kicked off
a bunch of projects short projects so
those previous projects are all
multi-year projects these were all
six-month projects so adversarial
machine learning is of great interest to
many people and what we're doing there
is Bayesian deep learning and not just
because I'm a Bayesian actually they
gave that run this project it's also
Bayesian so that's why I thought it was
a great idea so there's a natural
combination of things but what we doing
there is essentially spotting out of
distribution data points and quantifying
yet the probability that those kinds of
data points are adversarial related or
I'm just so really generated we'll be
doing some work with the national
cybersecurity Center so GCHQ has a an
arm of she said q which is called the
national cybersecurity center and
they're tasked with ensuring the UK is
safe from a cyber security perspective
and so we've been doing some cool work
around Demark analyzing Demark data and
analyzing different interesting data
sets to characterize the UK government's
web footprint and you may think that's
easy but actually when a fires
in the middle of countryside in the
middle of nowhere in the UK sets up a
website on GoDaddy or wherever and pays
them 20 pounds you don't necessarily
always know that that websites been
created from a central government
perspective yet you're responsible for
ensuring that it's where the
government's responsible for ensuring
that it's protected in some to some
extent and so we've been trying to help
them to understand that work and the
final piece I'll touch upon is
evaluating common morphic encryption so
we've just opened sourced a software
platform which we call sheep can't run
what the acronym stands for but it's one
of these nice recursive acronyms and
what that is is taking on a morphic
encryption primitives so the addition
multiplication operations and the
different implementations of those and
actually providing a benchmarking
platform through which people you know
when you when the clever mathematicians
generates a new fhe related algorithm
they can push it on this platform and
then compare and contrast their kind of
runtime performance as well as some of
the mathematical assumptions that are
baked into these different algorithms
and so we noticed that in the
multi-party computation world there's a
benchmarking platform but there wasn't
one in the fhe world
so we've now generated this platform
there's a paper just ICML on this
platform and hopefully we'll see some
adoption of that the reason I mentioned
that is obviously sizing if that's of
interest if you're an fhe person then
please do kind of have a look at sheep
and see whether it it's of interest to
you so what I tried to do is kind of
like cover not so quickly so I apologize
for that quite a lot of the work that
we're doing at the Institute I didn't
really touch upon some of the ethics
side of things and some of the more
Social Sciences side of things partly
because that's not my technical
background and I wouldn't do them I
would do them a disservice if I tried to
explain what we're doing in the area of
data ethics but we're doing a lot on
that side of the spectrum and working
with lawyers working with more other
kind of philosophers as it were trying
to kind of help the governments and
organizations of different kinds ensure
that they use data in an ethical
kind of legally compliant and changing
the UK law such that we are ethically
responsible in the use of data and I
think that's quite an interesting area
from a cyber security perspective so
there's something that I've recently
kind of been thinking about I'm sorry
what say anything profound at the
moments but I think it's an area that we
should as for those of you that are
cyber security related research you
should start to think about a little bit
more than we currently perhaps do so
I'll start to segue now into a bit more
of technical content so I was kind of
interested so I joined the Alan Turing
Institute's for many reasons partly
because it's the kind of national
institutes at the UK in the UK and
partly because of the brand the brand of
the man himself and the brand of the
university partners and the Institute's
essentially trades off all of those
brands and that's what gives us great
convenient power and also allows us to
create national level impact and so I
was kind of interested in Alan Turing
and what he did and so I started to read
some papers of his and papers that were
written about him and it turns out you
may suspect I would say this that I'll
ensuring himself I would plus him
perhaps maybe not one of the first brew
certainly one of the first data
scientists that I've come across that
that's through my limited kind of
reading in a kind of history he was a
statistical data scientist specifically
at Bletchley Park and why do I say that
well I'll give you some citations and
some quotes from him and to kind of
demonstrate that that's partly true but
if if data science is the combination of
different scientific disciplines to
derive value from data then during in
his work at Bletchley Park essentially
that's what he did so in hotate Apple
actually Park he had linguists he had I
guess the kind of first computer
scientists he had hardware engineers I'm
quite crucially he had Jack good as a
statistician which was helping to guide
him that was the bun Rieu Smurfs
algorithm in all the work they did in
deciphering enigma and so I I kind of
proposed that well rather the literature
and I proposed that Joran was a
statistical data scientist and so the
Institute has
was quite a natural kind of link back to
the Turing and his work and then if we
focus in on Alan Turing's view of
probability so there is a really cool
paper so back in 2012 i'll ensuring
appeared on archive which is not
something that happens every day and
when you get a notification telling you
that your rings just appeared on archive
but GCHQ kindly openly published
Declassified and openly published a
paper of Touring's in 2012 and you can
go on the internet and download this
either from archive because somebody's
typed it up or you can see the original
manuscripts which was handwritten and
the paper by during which was written in
1941 but like I say only published in
2012 and Title II application of
probability to cryptography now my um my
mathematical knowledge being a
statistician isn't as great as I'd like
it to be and so I don't fully well I
actually do understand the cryptography
that goes on in this paper I don't fully
understand cryptography in in any
meaningful sense but I do understand the
probability side of things that he
presented thankfully and some of the key
quotes that come from this paper that's
actually there's a great guy a great
us-based academic called Sundin Zabel
who's done quite a lot of work on the
history of shoring and provided
commentary on this paper which so if
your interest in this paper uh suggest
you also read this accompanying paper
which provides a commentary and it's
actually some disabled that pulled out
some of these quotes so this to me is
evidence that touring was a bayesian is
a bayesian was a Bayesian I guess and
the use of Bayesian statistics through
World War two was actually the key thing
that helps us to decipher enigma
allegedly can have you know win the win
the war and so on Bayesian statistics
you know if I extrapolate follow-up
based in statistics and Bayesian
methodology helped to win the one that's
quite extraordinary given that Bayesian
statistics and the forties was seen as
something that one should never do
and so from you know my hats is further
off to Alan Turing for actually
persevering with a Bayesian methodology
in utilizing this and in the way that
I'll describe in a moment to released a
high-level so touring said in his
manuscript the probability of events on
certain evidence is the proportion of
cases in that which an event may be
expected to happen and given that
evidence so that kind of loosely
suggests that his amazing is thinking
about conditional probabilities that's
my interpretation not statements but
then more specifically he talked about
the evidence concerning the possibility
of an event occurring usually divides
into a part about which statistics are
available ie likely a function under
less definite parts about which one can
only use one's judgments ie prior
knowledge we combine those in a
mathematically rigorous way as you all
know because I'm sure some of your
Bayesian in this audience oh I hope you
are and and we get posterior
distribution so that suggests Jordan was
Bayesian actually what really suggests
children was a Bayesian was the quotes
which directly states that nearly all
applications of probabilities
cryptography depend on the facts of
principle or base theorem so back in
nineteen forties Bayesian statistics
were being used and essentially what
we're computing was base factors and we
introduced some cool computational tools
the deaths upon their Saban was
introduced basically in the same way
that was you know the computer
scientists and the audience was used
computational tricks to improve
computational complexity the discipline
was introduced back in the 40s to do
exactly that
so some cool things that we kind of do
now almost naturally as a data science
community that they were doing in hot
eight back in the 1940s which I find
quite inspirational and again there's
another great paper by Jack good and
this stuff yeah the work that they were
doing in would say really started so not
leaked but started to appear in the open
literature around 1980s
so again Jack good I have kind of
infinite respects for these kinds of
academics who were utilizing you know
big proponents of these kinds of
methodologies that were completely out
of favor during the period in during the
forties and yet they persevered they
they knew that this changed the kind of
the course of the war in specific ways
in which the
sliced relatively simple ways in which
the utilize these methodologies and they
were constantly told by the rest of the
academic community that Bayesian
statistics was just not useful in any
way shape or form
and yet they had to keep that they had
to bite the lip and not actually release
any of this stuff so and it's remarkable
I'm not sure I would have the
self-control to be able to to not leak
all secrets maybe I shouldn't say that
actually I have the self-control just in
case anybody's watching and so that
leads me to to to kind of my interest
which is I want to be able to build a
Bayesian model for cyber security or
specifically in this context network
based cyber security and I think there
are four key things that we need to do
and I'm not doing any of these yet I
should say there's and kind of right at
the beginning of this journey I'll be
interested in anybody's thoughts in any
of these things and I'll allude to the
kinds of problems that sits within these
things so I think the King hearings are
as follows so chain event graph
essentially a way in which one can
undertake causes a little causal
specific Bayesian analysis but causal
statistical analysis and represents the
causality between events using event
trees and this is a general chain event
graphs are a generalization of entries
those you that don't know them and
eliciting you know great expertise from
people at Josh and and others are volts
cyber security systems about adversaries
about how they work about systems of
systems what supply chains etc building
all of that into quite a complicated
statistical causal Bayesian model using
this chain and grant event graph
methodological system to represent
what's going on in the real world so
that's the incorporation of prior
knowledge as it were and so I'm
particularly interested in Chen event
graphs I've got I've just started a
project which is actually looking not at
cyber security it's although I'm hoping
it will translate since that so I've
looked I'm starts to project using chair
event graphs which is looking at how an
individual will go from kind of minor
radicalization to full radicalization to
kind of take in part in some kind of
terror
related attack in you know western
country and looking at the kind of
sociological evolution them as it were
an individual psychological and
sociological kind of surroundings
evolution through that path from being
you know somebody like myself all the
way through to somebody being very
radicalized and Mel I'm performing in
tuk
and that has analogies in some respects
to the kind of cybersecurity kill chain
and so I'm hoping that the learnings
from that work will translate across
into these the cyber wealth terms of so
we've got our own ability to do causal
inference assuming that this stuff works
the next thing I'm interested in is
horizontally scalable inference so I am
particularly interested in scalable
statistical methods so things that sit
on top of platforms such as spark and
what I see a lot of the time in spark
related applications is that people like
to count and that's great and we do a
lot of summarization through counting
lots of things but that's not that's not
the most sophisticated one can do with
with respect to statistics so what I
want to do is to to get more statistical
sophistication into spark like
environments so we're currently starting
a project and open source projects that
complement spark ml well ml live sorry
which is looking at place in MCMC Markov
chain Monte Carlo related algorithms on
top of spark and so there's some
interesting challenges that exist when
you're trying to kind of perform MCMC
you've got a distributed data set across
multiple machines you're running local
MCMC algorithms computing local
posterior distributions or sample based
representations of those posterior
distributions how did you combine those
samples to produce a globally consistent
and statistically correct MCMC album or
rather representation asymptotically
correct representation of the posterior
distribution and that's what this
projects all about so we just started
quite a big projects as a collaboration
between Cambridge
Warwick Oxford and Bristol and the
turing institute on on just that topic
and the best thing we've come up with so
far is quite a cool rejection sampling
algorithm which uses perfect sampling
all kinds of things we'll be publishing
that very shortly computationally it's
it's horrendous even though it sits on
spark so we have the horizontal
scalability it takes quite a while just
to do one MCMC iteration so there's
still quite a lot of research to do in
this space but we do have ideas around
how we can kind of speed these things up
handling time varying phenomena I
mentioned earlier on that I'm interested
in things as function time sequential
multicolor etc and that's kind of going
to be the focus of the last few slides
that I've got in a moment and some point
process work that I've been doing I'm
using Markov modulated passing processes
which josh has seen now about three
times this presentation so apologize
Josh and then finally I think the final
key ingredients of a good cybersecurity
model or a good cyber data science
related system should be that the
techniques are privacy-preserving so I
mentioned homomorphic encryption we just
kicked off another project which is
looking at fhe based algorithms and
essentially trying to produce
homomorphic Lee does not the correct
phrase aichi algorithms that are a
classification algorithm so for instance
there's been a paper that demonstrates a
logistic regression algorithm that is
fully homomorphic encryption compliance
if that's the correct phrase he wants to
take that a bit further so that's
logistic regressions kind of useful but
it's not the most sophisticated thing we
can do so how do we take that project
and you go to the kind of the next class
of statistical classification algorithm
used in homomorphic encryption so this
project known as crypto ml and again
we're looking for collaboration
opportunities on that project so that's
a collaboration actually it's just a
collaboration between the hybrid
Institutes of mathematical research
which is based in Bristol and Warwick
University as it's done son the Turing
Institute's so so for me if we can
combine all of these four things we have
ability to kind of respect
people's privacy and utilize as much of
their data on the different and user
devices as possible but respect the
privacy we can hunt them till the time
very immoral we can operate at scale
when we're looking across computers and
we can incorporate prior knowledge if I
can combine these these disparate things
in there still disparate as it stands
today and I think we've got quite a cool
system I don't know how far away in
terms of time we are from this but this
is kind of my vision and this is the
work that I've kicked off from the work
that I'm doing personally and I hope to
integrate all of these and stand here in
say five years time and give you a much
better presentation and remember in a
study of five years ago now of
integrates all these this the system
that I've come up with it's all
open-source please rip it apart and tell
me where I can improve it and if you
think any of those ideas are wrong or
you've got any complementary ideas or
you just want to chat to me then again
my email address is at the end I welcome
the opportunity to chat to you via Skype
or zoom or whatever you I guess Skype
would be the favorites doing teams okay
okay so I believe some of my colleagues
from Imperial have and spoken here
before so I won't
I will repeat their presentation so I'm
now focusing on the little project that
I did with one of my students at
Imperial College
around the use of NetFlow data analyzing
NetFlow data and and trying to
understand user behavior on a particular
device using a particular class of model
planned process model known as a Markov
modulated Poisson process and show you
some results so I'm kind of the
presentation really started off quite
broad in terms of the joy Institute's
and I'm just not done for this
particular net flow based analysis so we
are Imperial College and collect net
flow data we have about 40,000 computers
we generates about 12 terabytes of flow
data per month or around 15 gigabytes
per hour and the kinds of things were
interested in so we're interested in
people trying to steal our intellectual
property because for Imperial that's one
of the ways in which we can generate
revenue and obviously then fund the
academic research that we want someone
to take and the training that we do
we don't want to impose lots of
constraints on the network academics get
grumpy when you tell them they can't go
and visits a particular website no
matter what that website is on students
in college halls really don't like being
told that they can't use the latest
illegal file sharing tool not that
anybody does that Imperial College I'm
sure but that's that's a consideration
too and and spearfishing turns out as
often the case there's a major
compromise routes for the network and
and I guess the fourth thing which is
always the case with sub security the
brand damaged that warm one could incur
if there were attack successful attack
or if such an attack was reported I'm
sure the husband several have a
successful effect you just don't know
about them so I guess most do some of
you will know this stuff but a net flow
record is a summary between two network
devices and it's it's collected at the
root level it's quite a lot of interest
in statistical issues around missing
data around duplication around direction
around time around session ization
there's lots of change going on and
there's lots of ways in which you can
analyze the data so net flow data is
really cool data set from a statistical
perspective if you're just interested in
developing statistical methodology and
that's kind of my interest really then
this offers quite a lot of different
statistical problems to motivates the
methodological developments that one can
undertake and the the great data set
that Los Alamos National Labs release
there's a greater step for everybody to
kind of access but I'm sure and I saw
you have access to some great data too
it's maybe you don't need that open
source data but I will advertise the Los
Alamos data not least because I'm
visiting Los Alamos next week and if
anybody's watching this they will be
pleased that I've advertised their data
sets so given NetFlow data are you given
metadata about the packets flying across
the network what I want to do is just
analyze an individual device and I want
to model user behavior so I want to know
just from the timing information of the
events on the computer can I figure out
what the user was doing ie were they
streaming were they on not necessarily
were they on YouTube but with a
streaming video were they writing emails
were they doing nothin at all what what
kinds of activity were they doing so I
want to come in further using a Bayesian
process and the basing process I chose
to use is a mockup modulated class on
process so what is an mmpp
well really simply what we've got is a
this is some other kind of more formal
detail but I won't go through this in
the interest of time what we have is a
hidden or latent continuous time Markov
chain which is denoting or rather
representing the user behavior so we've
got a finite state continuous time
Markov chain and so if the chain is in
state zero the users inactive and if the
state is in chain one if the chain is in
state one then perhaps the wrong
streaming video streaming websites and
so on and so forth so we have some
interesting challenges there both in
terms of specifying the number of states
so we've got a model selection problem
linking it back to Alan Turing's working
model selection and Bayes factors and
all that good stuff
so once we solve that problem then we
have an inference problem and we have we
want to infer the state and I you know
what are they doing on the computer and
all our likelihood function is
essentially a point Process Model A plus
one point Process Model I where we get
the event timing data and from other
than timing data we want to infer this
the state of this continuous time Markov
chain and there's some stuff on
continuous time Markov chains which I
will skip over because you're either
interested in it and you know it or
you're not interested in it and it's
dull maths that nobody really clear
spots but interesting math sniffle as'
and so the kind of key contribution that
we made so the first one was from an
application perspective we were able to
kind of as you'll see on the next slide
we were able to demonstrate that one can
infer some stuff from using these types
of methodologies the second contribution
that we made
was in terms of parameter estimation and
so from a methodological perspective in
that continuous time Markov chain what
you want to do is to estimate a bunch of
parameters or two promises which are
reasonable dimension depending on the
number of hidden States that you have in
this continuous time Markov chain and
you do that using e/m or give something
so it's all relatively straightforward
but from a an estimation perspective
what you need to be able to do is to
construct the smooth distribution and so
if your state space modelling if you use
if you are trying to compute the
posterior distribution as a function of
time as you get more and more data what
you need to be able to do is to compute
this distribution conditional and all
the data and i've emitted lots and lots
of details bits in the accompanying
paper what what one realizes is that
when you're computing the smoothing
distribution you run a filter forwards
across the data in time you run a filter
backwards in time and you combine the
outputs of the different points in time
this backwards filter is actually not a
probability measure in fact it needn't
be necessarily a finite measure and so
when you use sequential Monte Carlo
related techniques which you have to use
in this particular case to estimate
these distributions because the solution
dance admits an analytically tractable
solution this estimation of this measure
which is not necessarily a finite
measure means that these techniques all
the convergence theory goes out to the
window and so the the methodological
contribution that we made in this
particular paper was to guarantee that
this is a that the backward filter is a
finite measure at the very least by
introducing an artificial distribution
we did some probabilistic manipulations
so if you kind of remove the effects of
some artificial distribution that we
introduced and make this whole system
computable using the types of
methodology sequential Monte although we
have to use which is then embedded in
the parameter estimation algorithm to
estimate the parameters so it's
parameter estimation is very
computationally expensive once you
estimates the promises the actual
algorithm to infer this stuff to infer
the states of the user is actually
relative straightforward so we
just to kind of reiterate we've got
point process data we want to estimate
the state of this hidden state ie what's
the user doing and we use a relatively
simple algorithm to be able to do that
this mark and modulates a pass and
process I'll just make the probability
of the states at any one particular time
prior to that we have to estimate the
parameters of the system we use in our
case we used to give something but
within that give something procedure we
needed a sequential Monte Carlo
algorithm and we realized that there was
this technical problem about this
backwards filter not necessarily
approximating a finite measure and so we
solve that particular problem as well
and so that's the methodological
contribution then gets applied in cyber
security context in this particular case
I think we went for a four state
continuous time Markov chain but I was a
methodologically it's generalizes
practically and we go beyond ten states
then you're probably only wet in a few
weeks for your results to actually be
yeah to be usable so very good question
so one was emailing one was doing
nothing
one was streaming and the fourth one was
on Microsoft Word organization just to
see and so I can't remember what I think
these are the difference of the
different colors rock represents the
different types of activity be
undertaken so what we did was to get the
student to do different activities he
kind of were recorded the ground truth
and then we accessed his net flow data
from his device from from the college
and so this is the counts of NetFlow
data I think pinned over a five minute
time period I might be a minute account
room enough the exact details and so
that's the net flow data and these are
the results I mean what we do here is
just focus in on one part of that data
just to make that make it visible so
these are the different states this blue
line here is the map estimate of the
state that we believed the device to be
in
and if you believe me then then the
estimated state is often consistent and
always but often consistent with the
actual true states which I didn't
believe to be true I didn't think this
was actually gonna work at a thought it
was a cool methodological problem and it
was a hammer diabetic I had in my back
pockets at the time and I thought let's
try it out but actually and we were able
to infer the the true states of the user
on this particular device we don't have
any of the grunt reso don't know how
well it generalizes but this for me is a
particularly kind of important piece of
the jigsaw in this larger Bayesian model
that I was talking about being able to
infer what the user is doing from just
from NetFlow data with an Associated
kind of representation the uncertainty
is the key ingredients in building out
this system and systems better
representation and understanding what's
going on in the eye I'd have to go back
to the I don't remember sort of
wandering away Microsoft Word with
generating a birth data yeah I was
curious about there and so you know you
can discriminate Microsoft Word from no
activity so yeah there's several my
versions are worried about bathing yeah
okay it could well be I it could well be
the the onedrive relates it kind of
sinking like this I don't think we're
using the kind of you know that you go
to Chrome or Explorer overused and use
the online would but I think there is
qualit sink from going on your back
interest these days very missed you were
sad Network yeah so therefore it must be
really so that's that's all I wanted to
to talk about with respect to that I'm
conscious that I'm running out of time
but just to reiterate so the chewing
Institute is the UK's national level
Institute's for data science thankfully
drawings appreciation of Bayes helps to
change the world for the better
and and I said showing but actually Jack
Goods contribution as the Secession and
the theme is shouldn't be underestimated
as I'm sure many of you in the audience
know there are many interesting bayesian
challenges still to be solved I've kind
of alluded to some of them in my
presentation and the other kinds of
things the activities that were
undertaken specifically under my
direction and as you know big dates are
all deep learning deep reinforcement
learning deep something does not
necessarily mean that statistical or
expert knowledge is not needed and so
I'm still still gonna fly the Bayesian
flag even in the world of deep learning
and I think you know I think the deep
learning community and people are
knowing the deep learning community are
kind of I'm caught in on to that and
trying to integrate expert knowledge
into the systems that they're developing
in this presentation I introduced a very
simple Bayesian model it's not quite
what I wanted to present it's not quite
what I wanted to do in terms of it's not
as far as I'd like it to be but I still
think it's quite cool and we solve some
interesting problems
I hope this has demonstrated to an
extent the kinds of work that we're
doing puts churring institutes at the
forefront of research in modeling and
inference and specifically Bayesian
modeling inference we have quite a
strong community and Bayesian statistics
and for me personally I think you know I
always think it's good that an Institute
should be recognized for doing something
quite well like the vector Institute's
in my mind is great at deep learning
primarily because of the people they've
got associates about Institute's for me
we've got some really great Bayesian
people and I'd like the Institute's and
be kind of famous for basing related
statistics but again that's partly
because I'm biased in terms of my
background but I think it has quite a
nice segue to that so many different
attributes of our enduring but
specifically he's working probability
theory and then finally as I mentioned
collaborations visits presentations are
welcome for me from me personally come
and visit me or come and visit any of
our academic community and I'll set up
those interactions we could do that
virtually or we can do that physically I
welcome interactions any kind of these
my two email addresses please do email
those or if you're that way inclined
follow us on Twitter but thank you for
your time today and I welcome any
questions you may have
[Applause]
some model selection problem it's tough
right so you know NetFlow it's all over
the place
some of the edges have humans on them
and others are just purely machine the
machine driven and they they look a lot
different you know so have the bursty I
switch there's of Markov process so
there's a very smooth yeah so can you
talk a little about how you approach
your mouth selection there in that case
if not I've not approached it but what
would I do
I would probably come up with some kind
of hierarchical representation so that I
have an indicator as to the type of
device that the machine is so when I'm
performing the statistical inference in
the way that I described all the
condition on my my inferred state of
that machinery is a server is it an
access device is it and is it some
cloud-based spoke thing doing something
weird and so I would produce an
additional level of abstraction
introduce another latent variable in a
true Bayesian way and solve a particular
problem that's very consistently what I
think as well then there's this problem
you run into before that which is
figuring out all the different
categories that might be involved in the
mixture so the just servers and laptops
or is it printers laptops and servers or
you know what is the resolution at which
you want to have the mixture be resolved
to know you can do this with users and
machines and processes all of these have
sort of a mixture behavior to them so
yeah and that's why you know
interactions that's where the human
dimension does come in and expert
knowledge you you need to talk to the
guys that are on the network and at
least get their view on what's on the
network their main office Lee always
know what's on the network but I think
having those interactions you can then
better model the world and and
incorporate the uncertainty associates
at those models so again I'll kind of
reallocate the Bayesian methodology I
feel like I've hammered that
points a little bit too much today I am
pragmatic most of the time but as long
as the base in solution so um you talked
about using fully homomorphic encryption
and actually I'm impressed but someone
got logistic regression to work there it
seems like it should be really hard
because exponentiation is not a ring
operation um so but but you can so you
can evaluate using fully homomorphic
encryption if you want to do this in
some privacy-preserving way of course
then you don't have to know the answer
to your thing you evaluated for someone
but you can only do that if you get the
model from somewhere and and I was
wondering if you had any thoughts about
how that might be done in a
privacy-preserving way um
there's there's hope that one might be
able to build a bottle using encrypted
data but it's always off and the data
has to all be in her food with the same
key and all the schemes I've heard so no
is the short answer because I rely on my
my colleagues did that work for me or
with me and so no I don't have a
sensible answer that question so I'll
avoid the question completely under and
hopefully if any of my colleagues are
watching then they can email me and say
this is what the answer that question
should have it so no I I can't get in on
that question of having one takeaways
we're very interested right so that's
probably a real key collaboration
opportunity yeah here we all some
experts in that and there's something
yes I'm not either actually
mm-mom I fought to keep money put me at
a sign of its mmm-hmm so you took more
about this support honest chicks
district well your writing support for
next year
yes that's what just Park sits in on top
of - Jax compliance Linux kernel library
so if you google components of sparks we
had to rewrite and spark or rather we
had to ask Jack suffice some specific
parts of sparks either the project
really was about identifying which parts
of spark needed to be inside the SGX
Enclave and which parts didn't need to
be and so we have to make some subtle
changes to the spark code base and so
what we're trying to do is produce have
a spark environment so the users can do
whatever they want them on top of it's
just writing standard code and spa SGX
the spark SGX compliant version you know
the users invariant to the fact that
it's got SGX sitting behind it so I said
as a person that it doesn't want to have
to worry about the kind of kernel ish
level operations that one has to kind of
undertake to get STX to actually do
anything I can just sit there write my
Scala code in spark as anomaly would and
be fairly confident that the SGX side of
things will be taken care of through
this Linux kernel library and and the
spark modifications that sits on top of
those checks
better yet I'll kill the performance is
really from memory I think there's a
there's a kind of five times performance
penalty using SGX but I believe Intel
are making some changes to the next
firmware release which should help us
with that
there are still issues with SGX around
side channel attack some refuse and will
always exist but I guess in turr amps
claiming that those side channels don't
exist and so we're not fully secure in
the way that I described but you know
yeah exactly yeah so yeah there's a
couple of papers again on our websites
and and all this the software now is
open sourced so if you're interested
than grab it and spot folks and
countries and all the other good stuff
I am COC on this work yeah so okay
performance we have a deal um what we
don't set presents all we we get a
significant I mean significant reduction
in computational performance but at
least we can then paralyze across
multiple machines so at the moment I
would argue that one can't do anything
at all on SPARC with MCMC you can't
there's a couple of attempts at this
using kind of kernel based
approximations placing Gaussian kernels
of the samples and then combining those
in a I'll call it it from my perspective
rather kind of ad hoc way and so one can
do stuff but that there's no asymptotic
kind of relationship no guarantees that
asymptotically those approximations mean
anything I should combine all of these
different approximation so what we're
trying to do is be statistically
principled when we combine these
different local approximations but the
penalty for that at the moment is that
costs you a lot more computationally and
so the next challenges were actually how
do we improve the computational
performance of these quite horrific
rejections something related approach is
that we've proposed and so that's what
we'll be doing next but in the meantime
kind of open source in all these
implementations so that at least you
know if you have the time to wait and
and you care about kind of being
statistically principled then have an
ability to do something
I don't know we've only communicated to
the Cisco community of presence I guess
I need to go to the spark conference a
common but it's called now but the you
know the thing that happens every now
and again and presented to them there
and see yeah see what they say and the
statistical community seem to welcome it
but whether the spark community or
whether they're just happy with you know
the kind of out-of-the-box machine
learning based algorithms and and a lot
of the stuff seems to be SGD related and
ascent related and not but may well be
good enough and point estimates for
everything may well be good enough for a
lot of the applications and so this
stuff's not going to be relevant so a
lot of the community but for those that
actually wants to perform a full
Bayesian statistical analysis which
tends to be the case in my experience in
bioinformatics then this stuff will be
of use so they kind of you know win
books type community that community will
hopefully be able to translate and use
this types of technology this type of
technology well obviously you think I
should say is that we're hoping I think
I can say this we are going to be
hosting a ppl probablistic programming
language workshop next year so we've got
the standard community coming across and
we have over half a tool which pyro
thing is called a ppl language which
sits on top of the JVM quorum now but so
we're getting a number of different
communities across and hopefully this
stuff will be presented it's not a ppl
Brits kind of heading towards that
direction which is why I mention them
again if there's any I don't know I
don't know what Microsoft's doing the
ppl space and if I'm totally honest but
if there's any interest in from the
community and ppl and welcome your
involvement in in that workshop to